[Music]
Mr. Rózsa's surgery will be a
very complicated surgery
[Music]
if something happened if something went wrong
there was no going back
[Music]
and it's my scientific way fly x live' of
wadden the same culture
[Music  ]
god my name is josé rosas his
villalobos never
and i have six children i
have been spending time like this with her
losing my sight but it
is already a three month old drone that everything is
completely she has lost both sights you
need help from evil like  one of
where I am today or never with the family
I took everything to work decided
but the opportunity came like this to lose it
's vision today they fight for me and
work on the farm to live
[Music]
in Peru we are 1000 ophthalmologists
only on  10% is distributed among
all rural areas
in our mission at the clinic is to
try to reach the most remote areas such
as the pink designs that
are about two hours from the city by
a slightly difficult road
and be able to go and ca  Having patients in their
own homes gives them a bit of
hope and they see that we are not only
looking to operate on their patient but to
change their life, so once they decide to
come and have surgery
[Music]
we do it here,
you can exist,
make it better,
José Rosa arrived.  It really is a very complicated patient
the prognosis was really difficult
ok but for simple days
because this can be
hmm
a difficulty with opel a leader of
curing you at the forum cinema
with the rosa family we met on the
top floor to talk because the
problem of  each one of them was a
very serious problem and with a very
reserved prognosis electrical surgery could
be successful but
the organism did not react to what
we hope
very
jointly despite the fact that there is
and how long had this sadness of
having this nearsightedness  and since
I arrived in the room he never says I hope that God
allows me to see him to live
before Mr. Rosas's surgery
We had many debates to decide which
eye to operate on
or they told us that it would be best to
operate on both eyes, others said no
first the right or not the left,
that's where the doctor criticized. I know
I can, I'm going to operate on the eye that
has the best condition.
right in the surgical act
we decided to operate only one eye due to the
difficulty and the complications that
doing the eyes could have caused
later in the level of violence that is
experienced now the contributions in the incident
should continue and
we were so tense it
made us pray that  everything goes well
that everything goes well
and it is criminal from chance to send and
dysfunctional
the night like this praying to God last night
to rest who imparts a dream
that I said could be
could be
the next day the patch is retained
[Music]
open your eyes
there is light
the focus on the clear spark
and tears fell the doctor who
operated on me now sad
[Music]
she has done her job god too  he has
put his hands to do the work for me
and
[Music]
well